welcome to episode 4 of food flights
this istin one of my favorite things I
put in my mouth when I was in
Italy I went on a local guided food tour
when I was in Venice and while
everything was delicious this fola was
its own moment it was from an
award-winning Bakery and I could tell
the puff pastry was delicate yet crunchy
buttery not too sweet just absolutely
delicious and when we got it it was
still warm and it made me feel like I
was suspended in time a little dramatic
I know but it was just so freaking good
it's literally just layered puff pastry
glazed then coated with an apricot glaze
simple but that is perhaps where the
beauty lies and if you have the time to
make puff pastry from scratch go for it
otherwise a store-bought pastry like I'm
using here will take you on that food
flight this is delicious and I think
it's going to tie me over until I can
get my butt back to Italy